I make the full-scale model on the 4x4
cedar beans and each 4x4 that gets cut
influences the following one and so on
so in some way
the building of this is just a reaction
to what's already there
what happens with a piece this size is
that I only have a 16 foot ceiling so I
was only able to build up to about 13
feet and then I had to take take that
off leaving a chunk of it on the floor
and then building on top of that very
hard because I always have to be aware
of what's all around me you're looking
on the side of it so that's a full
different way of working
this is the pattern that gets thrown on
the plastic and then placed
this
but Colorado that crucible and what
we're after is this surface
I'm insured
absolutely the longest piece of lace
I've ever done you know would really
kind of ballsy opening one being
different from every other
I think the patina gets more long
we've been at this where I guess four
whole days so far
we have like three people on board
probably take another day or two
that's two circles out of it
a something that rotates very heavily
and then rub them on the surfaces that
come out and when I do that I keep
thinking that I want to pretend that I'm
the way in there I think it will be
perceived I mean it's something truly
majestic and magnificent and I think I
want to make sure that everybody
understands sort of what the underlying
aspects were not just the creativity the
the process that was involved to to you
know to actually create the finished
sculpture
you good
come down a while they all have to go in
not just right there kind of push it
around wiggle it shake it fry it until
we can get all of you started from there
you can use a wrench
I think it has such brilliance such
majestic presence that I think people
will see it as something absolutely
wonderful and I think it will be one of
the go-to sculptures you know it a
beautiful lace area on top will be lit
up from inside so that if you walk by it
will remind you of little synapses in
the brain and then it will be lit up you
know from the ground so it will stand
there just is a monument to art a
monument to science sure it's just the
kind of drama that I want and actually
so do the surfaces I also think it had
emotional stuff that's flowing from
I feel proud to have one of my pieces in
front of a place that also works on
helping humanity on making discoveries
that help with unearthing things that we
need to know
I'm gonna go through the early part of
my work actually it's not so long ago
that I did this very quickly so that we
can concentrate on CNT oh by the way CNT
amines science in Latin and the sound of
it always had the the vibration of a
woman CNT you know especially with the a
ending so this is a full scale model and
I'm going to go through this quite
quickly of some of a piece that was
installed in 2006 at Madison Square Park
this is the preparation at a foundry
that had Walla Walla in the state of
Washington trying to firm up the width
width of the plaster and the rubber
order to cast it in resin main reason I
used that is what the light does how the
light flirts with the piece this is the
most beautiful in that they feel almost
like scales it's very fragile it hangs
very close to the body of the piece but
there's an undercut in there and Sweden
to Jordan it's an island
the piece that can go in a corner it can
go on to the ceiling or it can just hang
as it does here and it starts with
something that's very squeezed and then
lets itself go as it comes down this is
a piece that is that of some creature
that cannot be told you know what what
it is but you can feel the way in which
it might move just by the way that the
belly hits the ground and in in some of
these and also to better in a detail but
I started with a circular structure that
was cut out of the inside of one of my
bowls that weren't working but it was a
there's a lot of shimming that I did on
it and in this detail you can see that
some of these pieces of wood sort of
shift from one another again sort of
implying a kind of movement one of the
first times that I left new cedar and I
do that a lot now and it wasn't all
graphite 'add and graphite is the same
stuff that's in your pencil but very
very finely ground that's the other side
and it actually sort of lets go it's
innards the piece that storm king he's
with an appendage this is bronze touches
the the ground
because it's so slender and it's it's
way too vulnerable as wood so I cast it
in bronze I'm sorry
way you and through this you can see
this colonnade of trees so it's a kind
of framing but it's not meant to be the
purpose of the piece at all hugely
voluptuous as it goes into its skinny
skinny whatever these are that Storm
King if any of you have ever been there
it's a huge park it's probably one of
the most beautiful sculpture parks and
you gets a sense of the scale here
winter my studio and I often have little
bits of things hanging around that I
thought one day might have possibilities
often they don't but sometimes they do
and this one's already destroyed I
destroy a lot of my work that I don't
want around anymore smaller this is a
piece that I made again all of this is
out of cedar four by fours and it's a
piece that really felt kind of boring
because all of the all of it had saying
that you know a little bit of the same
kind of thing as happens here he's sort
of wave-like structures so when I got
more carried away it it made more sense
he said the DeCordova Museum that's
resin as well now this is a process I
specifically included this just to show
you that this started as a bowl
and it was so boring that I sliced it up
slices and you see that each of these
forms are at a different level now they
sort of shim in inside more and outside
so that there is more going on and these
are shims that are stuffed in all of
their openings then I laid it down and
none of this was particularly planned
but I but I couldn't stand it standing
up anymore laid it down and cut some of
those shims down and this these shims
were not graph I did this white with the
blue tape on the rest was graph I did
but but ever so slightly you know I
didn't drown it in the graphite dawn
very important to me is that the
struggle of this thing you know the
lifting up of its of is of the back
portion and the taking itself off the
floor was important in the sort of
psychology of it why did we put the
lights back on and we can we put them
off again so we can see the image better
okay this is another view of that same
piece you see this is kind of the front
of it maybe this is another paper this
is a paper piece I made this this relief
out of cedar I covered it with a paper
called Ibaka paper that is a very
incredibly strong paper it's made from
the stem of the banana bananas bunch of
bananas that come from the Philippines
and you could imagine what that stem how
strong it is so that it's able to hold
this paper together so they can tear it
off the relief that I made would put it
put all the squares together hanging it
and the most beautiful thing is that it
drank the juices out of the cedar the
kind of color that I can take or this is
the kind of color that I that feels good
to me and I love
this so much that I made another one out
of the same relief and there's no more
juice to be gotten you know that was all
white so you can't this is a piece
called cross Mirage and I think I'm
going to go more quickly without
particularly explaining but it's kind of
a play with the grid of the four by
fours and the organic structures
underneath this is a piece at the other
the second great sculpture park in the
world is New York's or sculpture park
and has both of them have 500 acres so
that this is just a glorious glorious
view that she has and this is all cedar
yes I burn my pieces the latest piece
one of the later pieces where I started
going into the surface and this is a
piece that has also an appendage on it
but this appendage is faded to have the
same kind of perforations that the top
crown has on your piece and this is
vinyl that I'm putting on and their
little families that I get together and
much of it is horizontal but I don't
want to be boring and predictable so
that these this this this this arm is
not really an arms whatever that is has
you know huge indentations and then it
gets cast in what in wax
the lost wax process and it gets gold
there's the piece that the
Museum of Modern Art in New York this is
this was for me a huge breakthrough
because it enabled metal-metal often is
so inhumane or it's so uninviting that
to have these perforations have the
possibility of having the Sun the wind
the the air going through was was just a
huge you know huge visually and huge
psychologically for me so this is your
piece this is the bottom of your piece
this is how I started and you need to
start believe it or not and and and I
just take a piece of chalk and I just do
it it's not as though I measure it or
planted or but but that's that
determines the scale and it also
determines things like this is going to
be really deep as it goes off you know
this will give me some other options you
know so will this you know I mean just
this whole thing and has to be varied
because I don't want to you know bore
myself or anybody else the first layer
and then it goes on it grows this is
your piece it grows
this is olden and I'm sort of phidias
yes yes videos :
these are Lori's grandchildren they came
to visit me with Laurie and that's her
daughter Dena
that's right
see the top part of your piece and you
see the bottom part so altogether it
ends up being 25 feet and the very top
the five feet of the top is what is used
to make the wax the lost wax process
cast so that we can get all of those
those perforations looing of the piece
we glue one layer add a very very
labor-intensive it's almost like
medieval and then we make these donuts
so that we can transport it and so we
can stack it one on the other this is at
the foundry when this is this is part of
the result of the sand casting the
bottom portion of the piece about of 80%
of the piece that's the result of the
sand casting and this is the it's almost
like molten lava that they pour into the
cast molten bronze these are the
sections the sections that get welded
TIG welded and this is Tom fantastic
fantastic assistant and fabricator of
works was worked on my work for many
years knows and care is enormous ly and
knows what he's doing this is my making
a drawing for the crown part of the
piece for the top part of the piece and
this is what gets laid into the crevices
of the top part of the piece this one I
exaggerated the fingers a lot they're
not fingers and little flames whatever
they are you know they're they reach out
to the sky
considerably this is the lace that is
handled that has cut into through the
wax with a tool that vibrates something
like 500,000 times a minute
that is not vibrates but turns leave
that drawing that I did put gets put on
a plastic sheet and then the plastic
sheet gets placed on top of sleep the
wax already cast
oh he's welding under the surface is the
inside of the piece with Dennis working
on it who was another one that was
amazing with this piece spend a
tremendous amount of time we're welding
the lace onto the surface and I hate to
call it lace because it's not you know
I've never worn lace it's not it's you
know but but you know I don't know what
else to call it but holy
I'm putting on the patina this is how it
looks it's a brilliant brilliant rolled
color when it first comes out of the the
foundry
I mean first comes the first is cast and
then here I'm coloring it I think many
many different colors all those paint
brushes have a color that's at the
bottom and the nice thing is is when you
and it's best on a cold day when you
heat her body you know that bronze body
it starts you know affecting your own
body you know and she becomes almost
like this friendly mom
this warm mom but during a hot day it's
torture this is how she came in with
escorts in the front and in the back at
night
you see this is what it looks like on a
sunny day see it on a sunny day okay
do you have any questions because we
still have time yes sorry we actually
have a microphone if somebody I was
wondering when the lost-wax method is
most appropriate and when the sand
casting is the optimal choice lost-wax
can do anything you know it can do them
the finest you you could put your hair
into your model and it will record that
hair and it records it so thoroughly
that it drove me nuts when I did a whole
piece that was done in a lost wax
process because every single growth ring
and every single you know that was on
the wood itself would stick out you know
you could feel it it's like pimples all
over it and when I put the patina on it
it would really interfere with a patina
because those little protrusions if you
look at it sideways you know you almost
lose the patina you have to look at it
head-on in order to see in between all
these pimples so it's it's really fair
it gets fairly obvious and when to do it
but it has to be the lost wax in order
for all of the channels to be able to
reach when you do that that lace part it
is so fine it is so difficult to get to
get all to get the the bronze the hot
bronze it's where all the way that it's
supposed to go that it would be
impossible to do in sand casting totally
impossible yes
you don't have to collect the wax you
melt the wax and the bronze replaces it
the bronze is so hot it melts it very
very easily the big deal is to be able
to get all of the gates and they prepare
the gates for it furred many many many
days for each one of my thesis to have
all of the gates carry the bronze all
the way you know to to the tips of that
piece because if it's such little spaces
to fill but but but it's it's one of the
only foundries that I would trust is the
one that I weigh any any other question
yes George yes what material are you
using using to harden the sand there is
a special glue that they have and Tom
maybe you can answer that one or Dennis
what elves are inert find them I'm it
cures and it quite hard hard enough to
withstand
sand casting has a way of making it so
silky you know so that the whole bottom
part of your piece you know you can
touch and it just feels so good to the
touch and it's not true with the lost
wax process but but but I want the two
of you to stand up and I want it I want
to tell all of you how hugely hugely
important
these people are to
yes what are you doing now in wood
versus the cast I do would constantly
III make pieces out of cedar constantly
and you realize that for every every
bronze I've ever made is made out of
wood first but I consider that ahead of
time you know I I I know ahead of time
that it's going to be in bronze when I
make it out of wood but I'm making a lot
of wooden pieces yes you know I would
know I would know no better if I did a
drawing first or a model first that the
work was finished then I know if I do it
intuitively and often it's a question
mark you know often I have one piece
that I've been working on for 11 years
you know and I've been altering it and
I've been cursing it I've been you know
because it's so big I want it out of my
studio so I keep trying to figure out
ways to make it so that it feels
finished but the word finished is got
you know meanings that can be hugely
varied and and sometimes the beauty lies
in it not being finished as as others
would think you know but yes tom
no that's such a good question and I
would have such a hard time answering it
but for you I'll dig into my brain so I
think as a young child I understood the
world through my eyes through what I saw
visually that seemed most consequential
to me and it's nothing that I ever
realized you know I thought this is what
everybody did and I I grew up in a
pretty hard situation in Germany in
post-world War two refugee camps for
displaced Polish people and I I remember
being you know having one of the
barracks where we live being in front of
a bombed building that was substantial
had a lot of bricks that were they were
falling all over the place and I
recalled clearly you know but I didn't
realize that but I call clearly going in
there into that rubble and starting to
build things and getting this charge you
know but but it's not something that I
said oh I'm gonna be an artist I never
knew there was such a thing as an artist
until probably you know junior high high
school you know I was very naive I you
know I grew up in it in a place called
Plainville Connecticut which had which
had blue-collar workers and you know but
but I love blue-collar work but that's
not the problem but you know the
educational system was not great I don't
even know why I'm saying this but anyway
I just lost lost lost my thought but but
you don't you know I don't I don't think
there's a Eureka moment when you say oh
I'm an artist but I just knew that this
was that that what what I saw visually
what I reacted to visually was extremely
important to me
and you know I envy all of you
scientists because your brain is so much
different than mine you know you are so
meticulous you are so logical and I you
know and I sort of schmooze with
metaphors you know and I in my thinking
but but I think I think obviously you
know I've been married to a scientist
you know and we've you know he used to
he used to say to me when we were first
married we have very different cognitive
styles but instead of saying [ __ ] you I
just let it die down and it did I think
we have time for one or two more I just
wanted to say you're one of my heroes
like like David Bowie you know I'm an
artist and I became a professor and a
mother and I've had a chronically ill
child and I'm just so grateful to be
able to come and hear you speak to a and
it drives me back into my studio so
thank you thank you have an MIT techie
question but the the beautiful colored
surface could you speak about how you
achieve that chemically you say painted
but exactly how do you get that color
and then what can we expect to happen in
time is it protected or is expected to
evolve I fry the chemicals both they're
mostly chemicals that have to do with
acid onto the surface of the bronze
have to heat it up really really well
before you can put the chemicals on so
you literally fry it on and Paul ha I am
relying on you
you're already agreeing and you don't
know what I'm going to say to maintain
it like wax it twice a year so if it
gets waxed twice a year it will do well
and it's in the contract Laurie said
yeah yeah Ursula thank you so much this
gave us such a tremendous insight into
your mind thank you all for coming
for people